jetzt geht es um diese nicht nähern hier
um martin heidegger und seine theorie
derzeit in seiner schrift sein und zeit
da ist ja schon gezeigt drin also ist
eine anthologie alles was mit sein zu
tun hat ist ein und logie da war die
gute mann 38
und das ist wirklich ein klassiker
dieses werk das sollte jede
philosophiestudentin und jeder
philosophie studieren mal teilweise
gelesen haben ich sage jetzt nicht das
ganze ist sehr umfangreich und da kommt
man nicht ganz durch vielleicht selbst
in einem seminar das nur diesem thema
gewidmet ist kommt man nicht durch aber
ich denke es ist ein interessantes thema
und das sollten sie unbedingt mal
behandeln
und jetzt gehen wir da einfach mal auf
die leitfragen also wie verhält sich
heiligers zeit theorie zu den bisherigen
theorien
das ist eine spannende frage dann was
kritisiert heiliger am vulgären
zeitverständnis und wie hängen
zeitlichkeit der zeitlichkeit alle
zeitlichkeit dasein existenz miteinander
zusammen und das ist vor allem die
letzte frage das ist nicht besonders wie
verhalten sich vergangenheit gegenwart
und zukunft nachhaltiger zueinander wer
hat den vorrang von diesen drei ekstasen
sondern zeitiger und warum ist die frage
jetzt gehen wir noch mal ganz kurz auf
berg so zurück was war noch mal das
stichwort bei berg song wenn sie das
ganz kurz beschreiben sollten was ist
das verdienst von olberg songs zeit
theorie einfach ein stichwort was
kritisiert er
das ist eigentlich ganz klar
als er kritisiert die verheimlichung
derzeit wieder die verheimlichung
derzeit das ist das stichwort bei bergs
verheimlichung heißt letztendlich
zementierung also der kritikpunkt ist
indem wir die zeit am maßstab des raumes
messen werden wir ihre dynamik nicht
gerecht wir zwingen sie in systeme wir
nehmen ihr das organische dieses dieses
dynamik und das möchte also wirksam
retten und kritisiert dadurch die
verheimlichung derzeit und wenn sie
diese schrift die ich ihm geschickt
hatte mal ein bisschen weiter lesen
sagte dass wir auf diese weise auch
unser freiheitsverständnis viel besser
erklären können wie immanuel kant hatte
aus diesem diesem problem der
verheimlichung derzeit die dem er
unterlegen war nach bergs
geschlussfolgert dass freiheit außerhalb
der zeit sein muss das war der punkt bei
kant freiheit ist etwas was außerhalb
der zeit eine sogenannte intelligent das
ist so der punkt bei bekannt und das ist
natürlich schwer vorstellbar weil wir
doch eigentlich uns so erfahren dass wir
in der zeit frei sind durch die zeit
überhaupt erst frei werden nach kann ist
es etwas außerhalb der zeit geschieht
und dann aber von außerhalb der zeit in
die zeit hinein trägt und sich dann
bemerkbar macht sagt berg song wenn wir
die zeit anders verstehen und nicht ein
paradigma des raumes interpretieren dann
bekommen wir dieses ganze problem der
freiheit nicht dann können wir nämlich
freiheit in der zeit denken und es
findet also so eine art theorie der
person auch stadt das ist die folge
folge ist dann die wenn wir zeit anders
verstehen können wir auch die person
anders verstehen die in der zeit
existiert als subjekt was nicht mehr nur
für räumlich gedacht werden muss sondern
eben auch für zeitlich gedacht werden
muss
das objekt wird eben viel mehr dynamisch
und sein vollzug gefasst dadurch dass
wir zeigen wir verheimlichen
und da ist der ansatzpunkt zur heiliger
weil heiliger jetzt
hier noch einen schritt weiter geht sagt
genau da müssen wir also an sätzen gegen
die verheimlichung nicht nur derzeit
sind auch gegen die verheimlichung des
objekts und heiliger sagt dann in seiner
zeit und seiner zeit als wir müssen wir
sollten wieder davon ausgehen dass wir
es hier mit subjekten zu tun haben
da geht er noch einmal über berg so
hinauswachsen sagt wir sind subjekte die
dynamisch sind in der zeit existieren
heiliger sagt nein
aber wer sich nicht objekte heutiger
sagt schon gar nicht sind wir substanzen
also das ist ja gegen die karts
gerichtet die subjektivität das ist
gegen aristoteles gerichtet wir sind
venus blicken auch substanzen sondern
was sind wir welchen begriff bringt ihr
heiliger ins spiel
das dasein wir sind ein dasein ein
dasein und ein dasein ist 1 1 dem es 1
seines teams in seinem sein um sein sein
selbst geht also ein dasein ist ein
existenz also da sein und existenz und
das bringt ja einsatz haben da seien
halt immer dieses selbst bezügliche
struktur es geht die sind da sein um
sein sein selbst was heißt es also es
steht in bestimmten beziehungen zur welt
es gibt immer schon in der welt ist in
der welt sein und die dem es in der welt
steht hat es gespräche bildet es
bestimmte bezüge aus und ein ganz
besonderer bezug ist die sorge weil die
sorge kommt hier mit einem spiel sorge
ist eine besondere form der bezüglich
kite er selbst und fremd bezüglich kite
und heiliger wird jetzt dafür
argumentieren dass wir diese sorge
struktur zeitlich interpretieren können
ja sorge bedeutet nicht nur kummer haben
oder angst haben sondern dass eine man
etwas gelegen ist
ich besorge dass ich trage die sorge
dafür ich habe ich bin für sorgen
so muss man das auch
verstehen wenn nicht nur so angst oder
sowas und das ist dieses engagierte
verhältnis des der welt seins und dieses
dieses dieser bezug der sorge den sagt
heutige können wir nur dann verstehen
wenn wir ihn zeitlich deportieren
zeitlich heißt jetzt immer eben im
verhältnis von vergangenheit gegenwart
und zukunft heilige sektstadt
vergangenheit gewesen haid das ist auch
ein wichtiger begriff bei heidegger und
jetzt wollen wir einfach mal hier ein
bisschen weiter lesen weil heiliger
jetzt am anfang auch noch mal aufmerksam
zu sprechen kommt zudem kritisierte
viele neuere forscher sagen
heiliger wird berg song gar nicht
gerecht haltiger verdankt werk sondern
vielmehr als sie zugeben möchte so ist
es immer in der philosophie dass man die
vorhergehenden theorien schlecht macht
und nicht angemessen würdigt was man
jetzt von denen eigentlich noch
übernimmt das war nicht glaube ich ganz
fair von heute sagen jedenfalls neuere
forschungen jedenfalls kommen jetzt mal
auf den anfang zu sprechen
sie finden die folien auch wie immer auf
die lowcost die aktuellen folien die sie
auch jetzt hier vor sich sehen finden
sie in der app oder auf dieser seite
er sagt jetzt folgen es als der sinn des
seins des sein denn dass wir da sein
nennen wird die zeitlichkeit aufgewiesen
dieser nachweis muss sich bewähren in
der wiederholten interpretation der
vorläufig aufgezeigten gas seien
strukturen als mode der zeitlichkeit
aber mit dieser auslegung des daseins
als zeitlichkeit ist nicht auch schon
die antwort auf die leitende frage geben
die nach dem sinn von sein überhaupt
steht wohl aber ist der boden für die
gewinnung dieser antwort bereit gespielt
also her seit die auslegung dieser
auslegung auslegung ist immer ein
verstehen wenn ich etwas interpretieren
dann lege ich das aus aber aussehen kann
da wirklich dieses aus falten kann
wirklich also auseinander lägen die
differenzierung des daseins die müssen
wir zeitlich verstehen als wir müssen
also die strukturen des daseins sind
formen oder
die der zeitlichkeit wir können das
dasein unsere existenz nur anhand der
zeit verstehen und natürlich nicht nur
eine arie und nach einer b
da würde jetzt seitiges sagen die beere
ist ja das allerschlimmste das ist ja
die allergrößte abstraktion und die a3
ist auch noch viel zu abstrakt
weil die arbeit ja nur hier
subjektivität ermöglichen aber nicht
existenz das müssen wir müssen also die
uns die frage stellen was ist jetzt
bitteschön der unterschied zwischen
subjektivität und da sein was ist der
unterschied das ist die spannende frage
ein punkt bringt heutiger ganz am anfang
gesagt subjektivität ist immer nur ist
immer versus objektivität die täter
wurde auch versus welt und da sagt
heiliger das stimmt gar nicht sondern
haltiger sagt wir sind immer schon in
der welt das ist verteidiger und
deswegen deswegen es gibt ja auch mit
diesem paradigma nicht überein
er sagt diese unterscheidung zwischen
subjekt und objekt die ist in dem dach
oder subjektivität objektivität oder
welt sagen wir welt er die iss in dem
begriff des daseins aufgehoben weil
heiliger vom dasein auch so spricht dass
es immer schon in der welt ist als ein
modus des daseins ist das in der welt
sein
das dasein ist immer bezogen auf die
welt und es kann nie wie so eine
denkende substanz bei techart von der
welt entfremdet werden so dass die welt
dem subjekt fraglich wird hat diese
ganze problematik des skeptizismus wir
können mit dem wissen ob es überhaupt
etwas gibt was da existiert oder
existiert am ende nur allein das sagt
heiliger
das ist eine völlig falsche frage
stellte ist eine abgeleitete eine
abgeleitete problematik die gar nicht
angemessen ist weil wir eigentlich immer
schon in der welt sind
es ist also der punkt und er sagt diese
ganzen bezüge als subjekt wird
nachhaltiger zu wenig in seinen bezügen
da das da ist ein ist keiner bezug zu
sich selbst bezug zur welt zu allem
möglichen bezug zur zukunft bezug zur
vergangenheit so könnte man das sei also
ein sehr emotionales verständnis und
über dieses relationale verständnis
kommt eben die zeit hinein die zeit ist
nicht das sehr räumlich sondern das
relationale was auch mal wieder zurück
reicht nach vorne reicht usw
dass also der punkt des daseins sehr
relational subjekt ist nur so eine
relation zu blick wert ist optik und da
sein ist immer schon mit der welt
zusammen immer auf die welt gerichtet
und dieses gerichtet sein
auf die welt nennt eiliger auch
intentional i tät das hat er von edmund
husserl das ist ein vorgänger ein
bedeutender phänomenologie also muss all
ist somit berg sei in einer zeit
ungefähr und heilige versuchte zusammen
einen schritt weiter zu gehen
ja also diesen einfach mal weiter als er
sagt jetzt hier folgendes
andeutungsweise wurde gezeigt zum dasein
gehört als optischer verfassung einfuhr
und logisches sein dasein ist in der
weise sein so etwas wie sein zu
verstehen als es ist auch was das dasein
ist immer verstehen dass natürlich
wieder eine relation unter festhaltung
dieses zusammenhangs soll gezeigt werden
dass das von wo aus da sein überhaupt so
etwas wie sein ausdrücklich versteht und
aus legt die zeit ist diese muss als der
horizont alles seins verständnis und
jeder satz auslegung ans licht gebracht
und genuin begriffen werden und das
einsichtig werden zu lassen bedarf es
einer ursprünglichen explosion der zeit
als horizont des seins verständnisses
aus der zeitlichkeit als sein des seins
verstehenden dasein im ganzen diese
aufgabe liegt zugleich die forderung den
so gewonnenen begriff derzeit gegen das
vulgäre zeitverständnis abzugrenzen das
explizit geworden ist in einer zeit
auslegung wie sie sich im traditionellen
zeit niedergeschlagen hat der sich seit
aristoteles bis über bergson da haben
wir jetzt hier zwei unserer kandidaten
hinaus durch hält dabei ist deutlich zu
machen dass und wie dieser zeit begriff
und das vulgäre zeitverständnis
überhaupt aus der zeitlichkeit
entspringen
damit wird dem vulgären zeitbegriff sein
eigenständiges recht zurückgegeben
entgegen der these berg songs die mit
ihm gemeinde zeit sei der raum was ist
jetzt also die kritik was möchte heutige
zu machen
haben sie eine idee
und ob ich keine zeit uns kommt jetzt
hast du immer wenigkeit haben sie wissen
sie was wohl eigentlichkeit ist ja es
ist ja genau
ja richtig ein wichtiger anderer begriff
ist noch dass man dass man das was man
als anonyme das einfach in der menge so
aufgehen sich somit treiben lassen
das ist auch noch ein wichtiger punkt
und damit mag dieses rückkehrer zeit
verstandes zusammenhängen
jedenfalls entwerfen wir uns in diesem
vulgären zeitverständnis nicht sondern
wir könnte vielleicht sagen man
unterliegt derzeit treibt in der zeit
wird in der zeit getrieben oder die zeit
läuft auf einen zu
ja das ist dieses passive
zeitverständnis nun also man schwimmt in
der zeit im strom der zeit man schwimmt
eigentlich gar nicht sondern im strom
der zeit mitgerissen oder die zeit kommt
auf uns sowieso ein schicksal und gemäß
beiden verständnis die wir ja über die
a3 beschreiben können sind wir passiv
darin
wir unterliegen ihr das könnte man so
ein bisschen als diese wohl gern zeit
bitten verstehen und wir müssen aber um
zu existieren müssen wir zeit
dynamisieren wir müssen zeit als wir
hier sagt ein auge zu und verstehen
innerhalb dessen überhaupt existiert
werden kann und auch verstanden werden
kann also zeit nichts dass er als ein
flur jedes medium sondern als eine
horizont das ist in einer horizont ein
horizont ist etwas was etwas abgrenzt ja
also sozusagen die zeit ist der hier
sind wir und die zeit ist der horizont
zeit wird zu einer grenze einer
bedingung der möglichkeit könnte man
vielleicht sagen mit kann
trans zentral die bedingung ist die die
zeit ist die bedingung der möglichkeit
um sich überhaupt entwerfen zu können zb
um pläne zu machen um etwas zu lernen
aus der vergangenheit da wird jetzt mit
zeit ganz anders umgegangen als nur so
dass man eben in der zeit steht und die
zeit auf uns zu stunden das heißt wir
werden wie engagieren uns mit der zeit
derzeit wird für unser selbstverständnis
bedeutsam und sagte hier also
das vulgäre zeitverständnis beschreibt
nicht genau aber möchte dem wohl gern
zeitverständnis sein eigenes recht
zugestehen also das wohl derzeit
verständnis wird zu einem modus des
daseins auch wenn es ein defizitärer
modus des daseins
es wird also nichts was einfach so
ausgeschlossen wird sondern es wird
gewissermaßen aufgehoben also man kann
von einer höheren warte aus plötzlich
erkennen dass das vulgäre
zeitverständnis eben ein modus
vielleicht der verfallen hyde ist oder
ein modus des man ist wenn man einfach
im zeit strom fließt und nichts was also
ausgeschieden werden musste da widerlegt
werden muss ein heiliger hat als die
große stärke der heimischen philosophie
ist das alles mit aufnimmt also selbst
aus seiner sicht verfehlte formen sind
nicht einfach fehler die es zu schließen
gilt sind es sind weisen unsere existenz
die ihre berechtigung haben aber die
erst im durchlaufen überbieten
zurechtgewiesen werden könnte man sagen
in dieser sehr integrativen form das
falsche nicht einfach nur als das
äußerliche oder das zu verdammen oder
wie auch immer anzusehen sondern als
modus der entwicklung an sind da
gleichzeitiger sehr wissen sie welchen
philosophen etwa gleich ja genau ich
habe es ja auch schon gesagt also diese
aufheben jeglic denkt das genauso dann
muss sagen heiliger denkt genauso wie
hegel als ekel denkt auch jede form des
fehlers wer sich einfach schlecht dass
äußerliches sondern es ist eine station
ein moment in einer viel größere
entwicklung also im fehler ist die
wahrheit schon angelegt sagte klitz und
da ist auch was dran weil wenn sie sich
irren können sie nämlich sagen dass wenn
sie sich ihren die möglichkeiten
bedeutet dass sie immer schon an der
wahrheit orientiert sind
sie haben nicht den richtigen zugriff
aber sie haben sich schon was gedacht
wenn sie zb sich irren oder enttäuscht
werden dann heißt es sie haben ein
proposition also ein eine vermutung
gehabt sie haben eine internationale
einstellung und diese position hat als
falsch herausgestellt aber sie haben
dadurch nicht nichts gemacht sie waren
an mit der wahrheit zugang ja sag ich
mal und das ist eine wichtige intuition
und heiliger nimmt das von hegel also
auf aber er macht das noch auf eine
existenzielle weise bei hegel wird das
alles zu einem logischen prozess und zu
einem auch irgendwie anonymen logischen
prozessregeln spielt das eigentlich
individuum als solches dann keine rolle
mehr sein es wird aufgehoben und eine
viel größere und ein heiliger möchte
eben ich sage jetzt nicht das individuum
aber die existenz mit seinen sorgen und
so weiter und so fort das möchte
heiligen besonders akzentuieren hegel
hingegen würde sowas wie sorge wohl ihr
in die psychologie nehmen auch wenn er
dann interessanterweise auch bezogen auf
metaphysische themen plötzlich von einem
schmerz spricht oder vielleicht auch von
einer angst also beheben kommt dann ganz
interessanter weise bei einer
metaphysischen abstrakten themen der
sehr konkret existenzielle begriffe ins
spiel wie zum beispiel schmerz und dann
ist die frage ist es jetzt metaphorik
oder warum bringt das jetzt her
eigentlich ist es sehr konsequent das
hat er gesagt die sorge ist nichts
psychologisches die sorge ist nichts
kontingentes und die sorge ist was
absolut notwendiges eine grundbedingung
unsere existenz nichts abgeleitete auch
kein gegenstand der psychologie das ist
so zum zug ist ein gegenstand der
ornithologie dass es doch mal sparen
also die ganzen metaphysiker der
geschichte wie descartes und sie hätten
sich nie über die sorge gedanken gemacht
über die angst nein halt gesagt nein das
ist es eigentlich anliegen der unglücke
alles andere ist nur abstrakt und rücken
ein weiteres ist das dasein ist ihm
selbst hinsichtlich seiner existenz
eigentlich oder uneigentlich erschlossen
existieren versteht sich so zwar dass
dieses verstehen kein pures erfassen
darstellt sondern das existenzielle sein
dass faktischen sein können es ausmacht
das erschlossene sein ist das eines
seinen teams um dieses sein geht das
sind dieses 1 dh die sorge der diese in
ihrer konstitution ermöglicht macht
ursprünglich dass sein dass sein können
es aus der science sinn des daseins ist
nicht ein frei schwebendes anderes und
außerhalb seiner selbst sondern dass ich
verstehen da sein selbst was ermöglicht
das sein des daseins und damit dessen
faktische existenz also den sinn
hier ist natürlich die frage was ist der
sinn gibt zwei möglichkeiten der sinn
sowie ein geruchssinn und einen sinn
haben so interpretiert dass jetzt der
buchheim professor kann aber das
leuchtet mir nicht so ganz ein
interpretiere also wie sie
wahrscheinlich auch sinn ist einfach die
bedeutung so erledigt das eine die
bedeutung dass etwas überhaupt bedeutsam
wird die frage nach der bedeutsamkeit
die existenz fragt warum zulässig den
sind aber man kann das auch anders lesen
also sorge wie gesagt sorge ist ein
besonders exklusiver bezug des daseins
zu sich selbst und natürlich auch zur
welt und nicht nur mir so etwas wie
angst dass und dessen sorge ist auch
verantwortung besorge das jetzt ich habe
die ich bin fürsorglich so muss mit
ja genauso sehe ich das auch
heute würde das so auch sagen also der
sinn ist vielleicht wieder so zu dieser
horizont
innerhalb dessen das dasein erst an
existieren kann er sagt es der sinn
dieses science das heißt der sorge dies
in ihrer konzentration ermöglicht
natürlich sehr so dicht jetzt formuliert
also man könnte jetzt sind eben auch im
sinne eines vermögens lesen aber ich
verstehe nicht inwiefern 1 1 ein
vermögen haben sollte wie fan eines sein
ein vermögen haben könnten also ich
würde also ziehen würde ich jetzt so
verstehen als bedeutung also als das was
entscheidend ist das was von wichtigkeit
ist
aber hier gibt es ganz verschiedene
interpretationen als jedenfalls wie sie
richtig sagen nichts was da eigentlich
so außerhalb ist nicht äußerlich ist was
da herum schwebt sondern es eben ganz
intim mit dem dasein
ich lese es als bedeutung also das was
für mich von bedeutung ist was wertvoll
ist so was das ist und man sieht dadurch
das was wertvoll ist ist nur deswegen
wertvoll weil es in einem zeitlichen
kontext alles aller wert ist
letztendlich auch bei dem gemessen an
der zeit mehr
die zeit ist begrenzt heiliger spricht
vom vorlaufen auf den tod das heißt in
der endlichkeit in der endlichkeit
struktur da zeigt sich ihr wert einer
sache die knappheit nadi die endlichkeit
das ist natürlich das was überhaupt sinn
und bedeutung erst möglich machen
das ist so die these da geht es hin
prediger
sagte folgendes das entworfene des
ursprünglichen existenziell entwurfs
existenz enthüllt es sich als
vorlaufender entschlossenheit was
ermöglicht dieses eigentlich ganz sein
dass da sind hinsichtlich der einheit
seines gegliederten struktur ganzen
formal existenziell gefasst ohne jetzt
ständig den vollen struktur gehalt zu
nennen ist die vorlaufende
entschlossenheit das seien zum eigens
zum ausgezeichnet und sein können
dergleichen ist nur so möglich dass das
dasein überhaupt in seiner eigenen
möglichkeit auf sich zukommen kann und
die möglichkeit in diesem sich auf sich
zukommen lassen als möglichkeit aus hält
das heißt existiert dass die
ausgezeichnete möglichkeit aushalte in
ihr sich auf sich zukommen lassen ist
das ursprüngliche phänomen der zukunft
wenn es um sein dass da seins das
eigentliche bzw ein eigentliches seien
zum tode gehört dann ist dies ist nur
möglich als zukünftiges in dem jetzt
angezeigt und noch näher zu bestimmen
denn sinn zukunft meint hier nicht an
jetzt das noch nicht wirklich geworden
einmal ihr sein wird sondern die kunst
in der das dasein in seinem 1 1 sein
können auf sich zukommen
als es nichts was von außen kommt nichts
äußerliches sind das dasein kommt selbst
auf sich zu das vor laufen nach das
dasein eigentlich zukünftig so zwar dass
das volllaufen selbst nur möglich ist
sofern das dasein als sein dass
überhaupt schon immer aufsicht zukommt
das heißt in seinem sein überhaupt
zukünftig ist
das ist jetzt mal wieder ein typischer
satz diesem zuvor laufen so weiter und
so fort wie verstehen sie das jetzt
haben sie eine idee wie man aus diesen
sehr kryptisch und setzten hier etwas
sinnvolles gewinnen kann weil ich kann
mir das ja etwas grafisch besser
verdeutlichen haben sie eine idee
wie kann man das nicht vorstellen ja ja
ja ja also mama tot
das hat die grenze und das dasein sei
zwar hier und jetzt darf man sich das
nicht so vorstellen dass der tod
irgendwo da draußen ist oder sondern
jenseits ist ja seit der tod ist immer
über das dasein spiegelt sich ist es
läuft vor und es läuft dann auch wieder
zurück dass der tod kann man das
vielleicht ein bisschen an diesem text
hier so verständlich machen also das
dasein ist das seien zum tode das ja
auch ganz bekannte wendung von heiliger
zukunft meint hier nicht ein jetzt das
noch nicht wirklich geworden sei
geworden einmal erst sein wird als es
nichts
äußerlich ist die zukunft ist immer bei
heiliger gegenwärtig das ist ja
gesprochen
wir sehen also zukunft diese ekstasen
derzeit werden bei heiliger in ein ganz
neues verhältnis zu sich selbst gebracht
also nicht das noch nicht wirklich
geworden ich bloß die möglichkeit
sondern die kunst also auch immer das
jetzt ist wer das dasein in seinem
einzel auf sich zukommen also es gibt
eine bewegung des aufsichtsrats und eine
bewegung des vorlaufes ich glaube dass
man so verstehen muss sowieso ein
kreislauf das dasein hat betont als die
erste möglichkeit läuft ihm als
antizipiert den tod akzeptiert ihn als
die äußerste möglichkeit und versteht
vor dem hintergrund dieser müssten
seit sich selbst erst wieder haben wir
hier also die das vor laufen wäre das
hier
und das hier wäre die kunden sehen sie
das ähnlich oder würden sie das anders
verstehen
ich glaube dass man das in so ein
kreislauf bringen kann
diese bewegen hier zuerst vor laufen und
dann zurück laufen
und dann wird natürlich der tod als
möglichkeit antizipiert und
vergegenwärtigt es wird immer bezogen
auf die stars und natürlich kommt hier
dann auch die zeit in cincinatti ins
spiel da natürlich alles was derzeit ist
genau es muss darüber hinaus geht es
nicht ja ich glaube eben ist war in
einer der vorigen sitzung wo ich mein
mann ist eigentlich immer schon darüber
hinaus so meine angst ist aber das ist
eben das problem der grenze dass wenn
wir etwas bestimmen kann als grenze
müssen wir es eigentlich immer von zwei
seiten her bestimmen
aber das ist eine andere frage man kann
es durchaus so sehen es muss auch nicht
bis zum tod sein sondern es kann auch
zum beispiel einfach mal was zukünftiges
sein was eben vor dem tod so eine option
ist es halt hier vielleicht so ein
kürzerer kreislauf das geht natürlich
auch das ist natürlich klar das muss
nicht sein sie bekommen auch noch ein
evaluationsbericht mehr ja
das ist aus dem koffer und nicht aus
mäßigen zeiten unterscheiden kann 2003
[Musik]
also musste man am 18
es ist kein denken an hinten sind es
nicht die muster und die dollar kommen
eben gilt als 1000 jahren
der in der 19
und da ist es ist gestand es ist einfach
der zustand dass man sein
ja genau das wenn ich schreibe hier
entwurf entwurf kann vielleicht auch mit
dem vor laufen noch zusammenbringen
die frage ist halt die ob bewusstsein
nicht zu schwach ist also bewusstsein
ist er wieder im modus der subjektivität
und es ist sicherlich möglich dass auch
ein tier bewusstsein hat von sich selbst
oder nur bewusst seiner zwischen schmerz
empfinden also es ist dann ein ganz
besonderes eben bewusstsein 1 1 zeit
bewusst sein könnte man sagen ja es gibt
ja verschiedene formen des bewusstseins
gibt ja phänomenales bewusst sein wenn
sie zum beispiel schmerzen haben und das
haben tiere auf jeden fall auch
zumindest höher entwickelte tiere ja ich
weiß nicht ob als einzeller haben
bestimmt kein schmerzempfinden wenn sie
auch keine praktischen roden haben oder
so also das kann man ja alles organisch
zeigen aber zum beispiel ein hund hat
natürlich schmerzt ihn ganz klar der hat
auch bewusst sein phänomenales bewusster
und ein papagei oder ein delfin hat
wahrscheinlich sogar selbstbewusstsein
in gewissen stufe oder besonders
intelligente affen die sich dann im
spiegel erkennen
das ist dann natürlich was ganz andere
nicht das spiegelbild attackieren da
sieht man zum beispiel bei löwen oder
anderen wilden tieren dass die daneben
das spiegelbild angreifen und es gibt
bestimmte tiere die dann kapieren hab ja
das bin ja ich ja und da haben wir dann
eine bestimmte form von selbst
repräsentation als ein selbst modell und
das ist dann eine form von
selbstbewusstsein
man kann natürlich sagen es gibt eben
verschiedene stufen oder ja dimensionen
des selbst fuß sein und es gibt eine
besonders anspruchsvolle form und das
ist dann die des daseins das eben selbst
wo es nur möglich wird vor dem horizont
der zeitlich
und das natürlich zeitlichkeit für tiere
keine rolle spielt in ihrem
selbstbewusstsein
das ist belegt also tiere haben einfach
kein zukunft bewusst sein dass sie auch
sorge haben können so was kann man
wirklich empirisch zeigen also tiere
haben keine zukunftsängste weil sie
keinen begriff von zukunft haben wenn
deine ganz rudimentären sinne und sie
haben er sein erinnerungsvermögen dass
sie konditioniert wurden und schlechte
erinnerungen haben aber die zukunft ist
kein gestaltungsraum des selbst entwurfs
tiere deswegen leben tiere auch sehr
unbeschwert und wir machen uns wegen
alle möglichen sorgen damals wieder also
die sorge kommt eben dann ins spiel wenn
die zukunft als etwas bedrohliches oder
auch als ein möglichkeitsraum gesehen
wird der uns eben besonders in unserer
existenz betrifft und tiere sind nicht
betroffen von der zukunft weil sie
keinen begriff davon haben nach neuesten
forschungen vielleicht haben es die fina
aber das natürlich ganz schwierig als er
viel und besonders hoch entwickelte
waffenart sind eben die intelligentesten
tiere und ich kenne mich zu wenig aus ob
die fina
es würde nicht verwundern wenn delfine
auch seinerzeit bewusstsein hätten dass
uns bisschen entspricht aber jedenfalls
müssen wir dann noch genauere forschung
anstellen also das ist hier die struktur
die vorlaufende entschlossenheit
versteht das dasein in seinen
riesenhaften schuldig sein
dieses verstehen besagt als schuldig
sein existieren übernehmen als
geworfener grund der möglichkeit sein
übername der geworfen hat aber bedeutet
das dasein in dem wie es hier schon war
eigentlich seien die übernahme der
betroffenheit ist aber nur so möglich
dass das zukünftige dasein sein eigenes
wie es je schon war das heißt sein
gewesen sein kann nur sofern da sein
überhaupt ist als ich bin gewesen kann
es zukünftig auf sich selbst so zu
kommen dass es zurückkommt eigentlich
zukünftig ist das
sein eigentlich gewesen das vor
laufenden die äußerste hat eigens eine
möglichkeit ist dass verstehende
zurückkommen in das eigens gewesen da
sein kann nur eigentlich gewesen sein so
fern ist so künftig ist die gewesen haid
entspricht entspringt in gewisser weise
der zukunft jetzt bringt er hier ganz
interessant es bringt er hier zukunft
und vergangenheit in einem dynamischen
besucht und das ist glaube ich das
neueste was wir bei heiliger haben bei
berg soll ist es so dass sind ist seit
dauer sehr subjektiv betrachtet also
berg sound denkt zeit sehr vom
individuellen bewusstsein aus und
ineinander geschüttelt dynamisch aber er
würde nie sagen oder würde in ansätzen
sagen dass das vergangene im folgenden
noch anklingen dass er sagt er weil er
sagt ist ja geschafft
das finden wir hier schon auch aber in
dieser radikalität der bedeutung für das
dasein macht es erst heiliger wie können
wir jetzt hier die gelegenheit in dieses
bild hier ein zeichen
ja das ist existiert praktisch
existieren nicht aus
ja ja ja das verstehende zurückkommen
auf seinen gewesen also indem wir
zurückkommen also indem wir vor laufen
und wieder zurückkommen merken wir dass
da eine zeit differenz war
wir kommen wieder auf uns zurück als
etwas was immer schon gewesen ist was
vielleicht auch anwesend war
ja also ich glaube ich würde ihn auch
darin recht geben dass wir es hier gehen
müssen also wir kommen zurück auf die
gewesen heißt es immer schon
sehen sie das ähnlich und würden sie die
gewesen alt immerhin zeichnen
gewesen schauen sie mal die zeitliche
form was für ein
ein modus ist denn das gewesen
ja genau als ein eigentlich ein party
zib 1 party zib2 könnte auch sagen
perfekt dann ich bin wesen also
im englischen wird das noch ein bisschen
deutlich hat die haben ja noch ein
bisschen stärker die unterscheiden
zwischen tempus und aspekt ja da gibt es
dann die progressiv form albin und ich
glaube dass wir das so verstehen müssen
an dieser progressiven dimensionierten
zeit also was im englischen mit dem
perfekt eine progressive perfekt
ausgedrückt wird man das eben existieren
was einerseits abgeschlossen ist aber
nicht so abgeschlossen ist wie das
präteritum im deutschen ich war also 12
have been dieses have been bedeutet
immer vom aspekt das ist noch andauern
may have been working zins und so weiter
her
aber wenn man sagt jason kidd sonst so
dann ist es klar abgegrenzt dieses heft
bienen diese progressive form des
perfekt glaubt an die denkt der heidener
dass das immer noch am werk ist dass da
immer noch was hergestellt wird das ist
nichts äußerliches navi präteritum dass
das einfach jetzt abgegrenzt ist dann
wir wir ziehen das mit uns mit die
vergangenheit die die ist ein uns
präsent und vergangen ist etwas nur dann
wenn wir in uns in eine distanz in einer
differenz zu uns selbst bringen würde
ich mal sagen also gehen wir zumindest
reflektierend eine differenz eröffnen
zwischen einem gewissen zeitpunkt und
vielleicht indem man vor läuft
und erst wenn man wieder zurückkommt
kann man diese vergangenheit sehen da
ist ein weg zurückgelegt worden
diesen zurückkommen sieht man in der
distanz zur zeit zur zukunft wird erst
die gewesen haid deutlich so könnte man
es vielleicht auch sagen
also eine differenz begriffen wenn wir
zurückkommen erkennen wir sind gewesen
da ist zeit vergangen
von dazu zurückkommen
vom entwurf für das mit so einer
progressiven form im englischen
begleichen gewesen haid wesen anwesend
da hat man es ja mit diesem wesen es ist
im vollzug es ist andauernd ja ja das
als sie sehen hier bringt er das
alleinsein gefüge die vorlaufenden
entschlossenheit erschließt die
jeweilige situation dass da so dass die
existenz handeln das faktisch um
weltlich zu handeln um sich nicht
besorgt
das entschlossene seien bei dem zu
handen der situation dass das handelnde
begegnen lassen dass grundsätzlich
anwesenden ist nur möglich in einem
gegenwärtigen dieses seinen nur als
gegenwart im sinne des gegenwärtigen es
kann die entschlossenheit sein was sie
ist das unverstellte begegnen lassen
dessen was sie handeln ergreift
also vor laufen es ist wieder das auf
dem tod auf die zukunft hin
und die gegenwart ist nichts was einfach
nur so da ist sondern die gegenwart muss
aktiv betrieben werden ja das auch noch
ein ganz wichtiger punkt die zukunft
muss im sinne der kunst gedacht werden
also die zukunft ist etwas was
eigentlich schon im begriff enthalten
diese worte zukunft hat das dynamisch
des kommens aber nicht sie kommt sondern
wir kommen in der zukunft ja das ist die
kunst und es hat das den vorlauf und die
die gegenwart muss gegenwärtigen sein
sie geben war das nicht einfach was
vorliegendes sondern sie muss auch
dynamisiert werden also es muss vergeben
wird werden nicht einfach nur so eine
präsenz punkt zu vergegenwärtigen
das gegen gegenwärtigen das ist das was
es ist das begegnen lassen
also wir müssen auf die gegenwart auf
eine bestimmte weise bezogen sein so
dass wir überhaupt etwas in unsere
erfahrung treten lassen
das ist nicht nur so passiv dass da
alles in uns hinein rieselt auf uns
einströmt das wäre so ein pazifistisches
gegen wales verständnis sondern wir
lassen ist zu
das heißt wir öffnen uns eröffnen uns
und sind die bedingung der möglichkeit
als überhaupt etwas gegenwärtig werden
kann
das etwas uns begegnen kann es begegnet
nicht uns einfach irgendwas sagen wir
lassen es begegnen wir öffnen uns und
ich glaube so kann man sich auch diese
gegenwart vorstellen also gegenwärtigen
ist immer was aktive und nichts
passendes wie wenn man so vorm fernseher
sitzt da passiert das und das und das
und ich muss es zu lassen ich muss mich
öffnen dafür glaube so versteht er die
gegenwart der präsenz ist etwas aktives
genauso wie die zukunft auch nichts
fremdes ist die zukunft kommt nicht auf
uns zu sagt heiliger sondern wir kommen
auf uns zu
wir treiben auch nicht in der zeit
voraus und wir laufen vor dass man aktiv
ist und wir unterliegen nicht der
gegenwart sind wir gegenwert wir lassen
geschehen also alles wird hier sehr
dynamisch gedacht also zwei punkte also
einmal diese gegen die verheimlichung
das hat man sowieso weil er das alles
relational denkt und ineinander
aufeinander bezogen aber noch stärker
als beiwerk sein werden eben die
verschiedenen ekstasen die die richtung
der zeit aufeinander bezogen auseinander
entworfen und dann ist eben noch ein
wichtiger punkt dass die zeit nicht als
etwas passives verstanden wird was auf
uns einströmt sind als etwas mit dem wir
indem wir aktiv sind durch das überhaupt
erst aktivität möglich ist und jetzt
kommt hier eine schöne zusammenfassung
von heiliger
das ganze nochmal im zusammenhang
deutlich macht zukünftig auf sich
zurückkommend bringt die
entschlossenheit gegenwärtigen bringt
sich die entschlossenheit gegenwärtigen
tin die situation
die gewesen haid entspringt der zukunft
so zwar dass die gewesene besser gewesen
denn zukunft die gegenwart aus sich
entlässt dies der gestalt als gewesen
gegenwärtigen die zukunft einheitliche
phänomen nennen wir die zeitlichkeit nur
sofern das dasein als zeitlichkeit
bestimmt ist ermöglicht es ihm selbst
das gekennzeichnete eigentlich ganz sein
können der vorlaufenden entschlossenheit
zeitlichkeit enthüllt sich als der sinn
der eigentlichen sorge also jetzt haben
hier so ein paar als das ist vielleicht
das wichtigste zutat also erstmal ist
doch seltsam dass die vergangenheit oder
die gewesen hyde der zukunft entspringt
wir würden nur eigentlich sagen die
zukunft entspringt folgt aus die
gegenwart oder also alles was sein wird
ist dezimiert durch das was davor war ja
durch die naturgesetze und durch den
jetzigen welt zustand und außerdem
können wir dann auf das zukünftige
schließen all das ist abgeleitet die
zukunft ist logisch abgeleitet von der
gegenwart und von der vergangenheit und
er zieht es jetzt genau andersrum er
sagt dass die gewesen haid also die
vergangenheit der zukunft entspringt
[Musik]
und die gegenwart auch also die gewesen
haid entspringt der zukunft und die
gegenwart wird aus ihr entlassen
jetzt sagte das phänomen des gewesen
also gewesen ist jetzt ganz spannend er
sagt nicht dass die gewesene zukunft das
war ja widersprüchlich gewesen ist ja
party zib2 das wäre ja eine vergangene
zukunft und das ist quatsch ein sondern
er sagt dass er macht jetzt also schauen
sie mal auf die grammatik was macht er
jetzt aus gewesen
schauen sie mal grammatikalisch was ist
das für ein wort es gibt es ja gar nicht
was denkt ihr jetzt hier zusammen
gewesen
was macht er jetzt hier könnt ihr das
grammatikalisch beschreiben
ich sag nur stichwort partizip was macht
ihr hier mit den partien
ja
ja es ist richtig
also wenn man's grammatikalisch
beschreibt denkt bildet hier ein wort
was aus einem partizip zwei und eins
zusammen gesetzt ist nämlich gewesen ist
party 2 und dieses n d
das ist wie wir sind das partizip 1
prinzip präsens aktiv und passiv fakt
der vergangenheit also gewesen und ist
sowohl präsent tisch als auch vergangen
er denkt ihr beide zusammen also es ist
praktisch die vergangenheit die noch
anwesend ist die noch am werk ist ganz
interessant gewesen
ist dauer ja in diesem beruf ist es
gerade diese prozesse sind
all die zukunft von der zukunft her wird
alles bestimmt von der zukunft wird die
vergangenheit bestimmt und die gegenwart
bestimmt entspringt aus ihr ja das ist
also dass hier das entscheidende der
entscheidende wendung ist es hier
gewesen sind gegenwärtig in die zukunft
das ist damit haben wir eigentlich alles
zusammen damals die vergangenheit in
einer bestimmten modus sie haben die
gegenwart und die zukunft
wie sind
also die zukunft verleiht der
vergangenheit erst ihre bedeutung in
ihrer präsenz
ja
man könnte jetzt zukunft natürlich auch
noch so anders formulieren also auch
wichtig jetzt für die hausarbeiten wenn
sie über heiliger schreiben schreiben
sie nicht so dass sie seine technologie
übernehmen so formulieren sie das mit
anderen worten also nicht jetzt im
heimischen thermen der terminologie
bleiben das nennt man auch heidecker wie
es auch eine ziegelei gibt gibt es auch
ein heiliger also nicht in den
hausarbeiten dann da sein oder als da
sein können sie finden aber nicht
gewesen oder sowas schreiben sondern
immer schreiben was meint heiliger jetzt
mit gewesen was ist das seltsam gewesen
ist nicht selbstverständlich
das ist grammatikalisch ein neologismus
dieses wort gibt es nicht unseren
wortschatz ist ein kunstwort das dass
eine gewisse struktur hat das praktisch
die präsenz der vergangenheit die die ja
die präsenz die fortdauernde präsenz der
vergangenheit bezeichnet soll es wird
ist mir ganz wichtig überall bei allen
philosophen wenn die ist sehr starke
eigene begriffe bildern gibt es auch bei
km anerkannt vor allem bei heilige unter
hegel regel haben wir nicht plant möchte
ich im ihn einlegen dann nicht in deren
begrifflichkeit die hausarbeit zu
schreiben
aus einer anderen begrifflichkeit sie
müssen also über setzen weil die
begriffe ist als solches überhaupt
nichts klar machen eigentlichkeit ist
überhaupt nicht klar was eigentlich kyte
ist sorge ist überhaupt nicht klar was
sorge ist ich sorge
meine angst was ist sorgt also dass das
einfach als einen wichtigen hinweis für
die hausarbeit also aus der zukunft wird
die vergangenheit und die gegenwart
abgeleitet aber so dass eben
vergangenheit und zukunft nichts
statisches sind nichts vorliegendes
zinsen dass sie eben auf das dasein
bezogen sind und aktivistisch dynastisch
gedacht werden
und die zukunft ist sondern der haken
der punkt an dem alles aufgehängt wird
von der zukunft her müssen wir die
gegenwart und die vergangenheit denken
ja und die zukunft ist eben eine
aktivität oder ein modus des daseins in
diesem vor laufen und in dem
zurückkehren und was ist sieht es vor
laufen das ist die frage
man könnte sich das so vorstellen es ist
eben der raum unserer möglichkeiten
ja ich entwerfe mich in freiheit im raum
meiner möglichkeiten bestimme mich
selbst ich erkenne mich selbst darin
auch in auf eine gewisse weise ich
erkenne mich darin auch auf eine gewisse
weise
wir kennen meine gegenwart und ich kann
eben mich auch in dem ich mich entworfen
habe in dem ich meine meine entwürfe
vollzogen habe auch in meiner gegenwart
an das verhalten und ich verhalte mich
eben vor dem horizont der zukunft auch
zu dem gegenwärtigen ganz anders weil
ich es im lichte der zukunft tun
ich will etwas vielleicht und dann muss
eben die gegenwart dazu nutzen um das
gewollte und der zukunft zu realisieren
und das was gewesen ist wird eben in
seiner nach wie vor anhaltenden
bedeutung auch ein wichtiger faktor für
meinen entwurf oder für das selbst
erkennen aus den zukunftsentwurf heraus
aber da kann man noch viel weiter machen
aber das ist jetzt jedenfalls ein sehr
wichtiges zitat dass sie das mal dass
wenn sie eine hausarbeit schreiben
könnten sie da versuchen anzusetzen an
diesem diesem punkt
ja
ich lese nur noch ein bisschen weiter er
sagt jetzt der c nominale aus der
science verfassung der vorlaufenden
entschlossenheit geschöpfte gehalt
dieses zieles erfüllt die bedeutung
dieses ausdrucks für die bedeutung des
terminus zeitlichkeit eine
technologische gebrauch dieses ausdrucks
muss zunächst alle aus dem vulgären
zeitbegriff sich andrängenden bedeutung
von zukunft vergangenheit und gegenwart
fernhalten das gibt auch von den begriff
einer subjektiven und objektiven bzw
immanenten und transzendenten zeit
sofern sich dass das dasein selbst
zunächst und zumeist und eigentlich
steht darf vermutet werden dass die zeit
des vulgären zeit verstehen sondern ein
echtes phänomen darstellt aber kein ab
künftiges es ist bringt der un-
eigentlichen zeitlichkeit die selbst
ihren eigenen ursprung hat die begriffe
der zukunft vergangenheit und gegenwart
sind zunächst aus dem eigentlichen zeit
verstehen erwachsen die technologische
umgrenzung der entsprechenden
ursprünglichen und eigentlichen
phänomene kämpft mit derselben
schwierigkeit der alle unter logische
terminologie verhaftet bleibt gewaltsam
keiten sind in diesem untersuchungsfeld
nicht willkür sondern sach gegründete
notwendigkeit um jedoch den ursprung der
eigentlichen zeitlichkeit aus der
ursprünglichen und eigentlichen
lückenlos aufweisen zu können bedarf es
erst einer konkreten ausarbeitung des
nur so gekennzeichneten ursprünglichen
phänomens also jedenfalls ohne jetzt
besonders näher ins detail gehen zu
wollen
wir müssen wir müssen zeitlichkeit das
ist ja denken er sagt nicht zeit eine
zeitlichkeit
also zeitlichkeit bedeutet das eben
alles was existiert nur im modus im
rahmen der zeit verstanden werden muss
wenn es eigentlich verstanden werden
soll und wir müssen ihnen abgrenzen von
diesen bedeutung von diesen strikt
getrennten ekstasen zukunft
vergangenheit und gegenwart
und er sagt zukunft vergangenheit und
gegenwart sind abgeleitete weise die aus
dem eigentlichen zeit verstehen
erwachsen
also die so naiv begriffe so die sich so
unmittelbar auf trinke aber die jetzt
nicht den eigentlichen sinn enthalten
also damit hammers diese abgrenzung wenn
die entschlossenheit den modus der
eigentlichen zeuge aus macht sie selbst
aber nur durch die zeitlichkeit möglich
ist dann muss das im hinblick auf die
entschlossenheit gewonnene phänomen
selbst nur eine modalität der
zeitlichkeit darstellt überhaupt sorge
als sich ermüdet designs ganzheit des
daseins als sorge besagt sich vorweg
schon sein in einer welt als sein bei
eher weltlich begegnenden sein denn bei
der ersten fixierung dieser gegliederten
struktur wurde darauf hingewiesen dass
mit rücksicht auf diese gliederung die
ontologische frage noch weiter zurück
getrieben werden müsse bis zur
freilegung der einheit der ganzheit der
struktur mannigfaltigkeit die
ursprüngliche einheit der sorge struktur
liegt in der zeitlichkeit
ok also jetzt geht es um die sorge
sich vorweg schon sein das ist dieses
vor laufen würde ich mal sagen in einer
weltall sein bei einer werde ich
begegnete sein denn
und dieses budget jeder wirklich
begegnen design.de ist das gegenwärtige
würde ich zwar dass wir gegenwärtigen
lassen gegenwärtigen lassen würde ich
sagen kann man so verstehen dass man
dinge erst bedeutsam werden lässt dinge
sind nicht einfach so bedeutsam
vielleicht in gewissem sinne schon aber
in existenziellen sinne müssen wir dinge
erst in ihrer bedeutsamkeit
wir müssen endlich ihre bedeutung erst
zukommen lassen wirklich sagen es gibt
hier den unterschied zwischen vorhanden
haid und zuhanden haid nachhaltiger und
das vorhandene ist einfach nur das
vorliegende was jetzt nicht einen
bestimmten mittel zweck kontext steht
und das vorhandene dass es immer
eingebunden
bestimmte kontext also mittel zweck
relation und ich würde es so auch
verstehen dass eben das gegenwärtig
kinder
gegenwärtig ist nur insofern wir es
einbinden wieder dieses relationale
denken ihnen bestimmte kontext also dass
gegenwärtigen de bedeutet dass wir das
was jetzt präsent ist in seinen bezügen
zu anderen vorliegenden dingen oder was
auch immer phänomenen erkennen und
bewerten hatte der stift hat eine
bestimmte funktion er ist nicht nur
vorhanden ist eine hat eine funktion ich
kann damit schreiben es gibt also eine
art technologie es gibt eine art von
instrumentaler dimension so verstehe ich
jetzt das gegenwärtige haben sie noch
eine andere idee wie man das verstehen
kann
ja ja es gewesen genau richtig hier
das ist gegenwärtig
herrlich anzuschauen geworden
wenn sie dieses niveau action sein genau
damit passiert immer dann zum essen oder
buch kaufen
und da ist dann ist das eben so das sei
genau so sehe ich es auch all dieses
vorweg zeit ist die zukunft des schont
sein vielleicht ein bisschen dieses
gewesen haid und dieses seien beide die
gegenwart das was wir begegnen lassen
so leuchtet mir das auch eine wir sehen
also alle drei dimensionen der zeit oder
ekstasen sind immer nur auseinander
verständlich und sie sind aufgehängt an
der zukunft das ist entscheidend also an
diesem entwurf vom intelligenz her
gedacht
und da ist natürlich gegenüber werk soll
schon ein fortschritt enthalten
es ist ganz klar bei berg sei das eben
sehr vom subjekt ausgedacht hatte von
der inneren zeit erfahrung und heiliger
macht hier keine beschreibung der
inneren zeit erfahrung heilige macht
hier eine knallharte ontologie also
denkt dass viel stärker und viel
gewichtiger als wirksam tut der xo wäre
nachhaltiger zu sehr an subjekt haften
und heute möchte ich mich beim subjekt
bleiben sie möchte zum dasein zu
existenz was auch immer das jetzt genau
ist aber existenz jedenfalls sehen wir
schon existenz ist immer dass sich
verorten und entwerfen und planen im
gefüge dieser drei dimensionen und
dieses dynamische aufeinander beziehen
und das aktive zeitliche gestalten und
es nicht passiv dem zeitlichen
unterliegen so viel können wir jetzt
schon mal sein dass sich vorweg gründet
in der zukunft das schon sein in
bekundet in sich die gewesen hat das
seien bei wird ermöglicht im
gegenwärtigen das haben wir ja vorhin
gerade gesprochen so kann man das also
verstehen hierbei verbietet es sich nach
dem gesagten von selbst dass vor im
vorweg und das schon aus dem vulgären
zeitverständnis zu fassen dass vor meint
nicht dass vorher wir sind es noch nicht
jetzt aber später ebenso wenig bedeutet
das schon ein nicht mehr jetzt aber
früher hätten die aufträge vor und schon
diese zeit hafte bedeutung die sie auch
haben können dann wären mit der
zeitlichkeit der sorge gesagt dieser
etwas das früher und später noch nicht
und nicht mehr zumal ist die sorge
werden begriffen als sein dass das in
der zeit vorkommt und abläuft dass sein
eines seinen vom charakter des daseins
würde zu einem vorhandenen wenn der
gleichen unmöglich ist dann muss die
zeit hafte bedeutung der genannten
ausdruck eine andere sein dass vor und
vorweg zeigt die zukunft an als welches
sie überhaupt erst ermöglicht das dasein
so sein kann dass es ihm um sein sein
können geht das sind der zukunft gründen
das sich entwerfen auf das um willen
seiner selbst ist ein wesen charakter
der existenzialist ihr primäres ziel ist
die zukunft
als diesen willen da haben wir wieder
ein zweck ein t los geht es um die sorge
auch nach dem willen sorge um dieses um
ist immer eine position die auch in der
sorge enthalten ist mit geht es darum
dass es auch eine internationalität
bezogen auf das aber auf eine bestimmte
weise bezogen wir natürlich auf mich
selbst sorgen auf eine bestimmte weise
und der primäres sinn ist die zukunft
also die zukunft ist das entscheidende
haben sie da noch bemerkte dazu als
jetzt leicht haben wiederholt sich das
so ein bisschen jedenfalls
[Musik]
sorge ist wieder wichtiger begriff
und er wendet sich ab von einem bloß
vergeben stündlichen denken er sagt dass
seine seinen vom charakter des rasens
würde zu einem bloß vorhandenen wenn wir
die sorge etwa als etwas begreifen
würden was in der zeit vor kommt die
zeit ist nicht ein gefäß in dem das
dasein existiert das da ist ein liegt
nicht vor wie ein gegenstand in einem
gefängnis als ob das gefäß die zeit ein
gefäß wäre das ist also ein falsches
wiederum für räumlichen das vorstellen
der zeit sondern das dasein existiert in
seinen bezügen dass das wesentlich
relational und die relationen sind zeit
bezüglich die auf das dasein
zurückgebracht werden sehen unseren
kreislauf oder diesen kreislauf erst
bekommen die ganzen ekstasen ihre
bedeutung
die zeitlichkeit ermöglicht die einheit
von existenz faktizität und verfallen
und konstituiert so ursprünglich die
ganzheit der sorge struktur die momente
der sorge sind durch keine anhäufung
zusammengesteckt zu wenig wie die
zeitlichkeit selbst sich erst aus
zukunft gewesen haid und gegen wörz mit
der zeit zusammensetzt
die zeitlichkeit ist überhaupt kein sein
dass sie ist nicht sondern zeigt sich
warum wir gleichwohl nicht umhin können
sie sagte zeitlichkeit ist der sinn der
sorge zeitlichkeit ist so und so
bestimmt das kann erst verständlich
gemacht werden
aus der geklärten idee des seins und es
ist überhaupt zeitlichkeit zeitigt und
zwar möglicherweise niere selbst diese
ermöglichen die mannigfaltigkeit der
science model des daseins vor allem die
grund möglichkeit der eigentlichen
eigentlichen existenz
das ist wieder ein typischer satz also
jetzt geht sie erst noch um die sorge
auf die wir nur so am rande eingegangen
sind weil dass es wieder ein ganz
anderes thema sorge hat strukturen hat
momente und die beschreibt heilige als
existenz faktizität und verfallen
das sind also
[Musik]
das sind dimensionen der sorge und wir
können jetzt was auch immer das jetzt
ist existenz praktiziert und verfallen
heutige ordnet jedem diesem moment der
sorge eine zeitlichkeit zu und zwar eben
zukunft gewesen hat und vergangenheit
als existenz wäre das zukünftige im
moment der sorge die faktizität wäre die
gewesen haid und die gegenwart wäre das
verfahren das leuchtet auch so ein
bisschen ein existenz heißt ja vom
lateinischen wissen sie was existenz
eigentlich heißt wenn sie mal schauen
hier lateinische kann man das so
schreibt kommt eigentlich von existiert
das heißt es existiere was heißt es
genau das heraus stehen
das heraus was ausstehen herausstehen
und das zeigt sich ja hier schon im
vorlauf nur das dasein steht aus sich
heraus zur zukunft das ist aus sich
heraus gericht nach vorne gewissen es
wieder eine verheimlichung also es ist
nie mit sich selbst denn der stand es
ist immer über sich hinaus und dem es
über sich in hauses ist eben auch in die
zukunft als ein möglichkeitsraum
entworfen
das ist also die zukünftige struktur die
faktizität das leuchtet allein vom wort
herrscher nein weil faktizität ja von
wackere faktum ein htc präteritum passiv
also ein gemacht test da ist die
wesenheit enthalten und
das verfahren kann man natürlich als ein
modus der gegenwart verstehen wir
unterliegen dem gegenwärtigen einfach
wir sind im strom des alltags gefangen
dass man die un- eigentlichkeit und so
weiter zu fahren
das hängt alles dann zusammen also es
ganz wichtig die sorge was auch immer
das ist die sorge ist eben eine
besondere ausgezeichnete existenz weise
dass da seins und die zerfällt eben in
zeitliche strukturen also alles ist
durch und durch zeitlich zu verstehender
heiliger
zukunft gewesen haid gegenwart zeigen
die phänomenalen charaktere des
aufsichtsrates auf zurück auf das
begegnen lassens von die phänomene des
zu offenbaren die zeitlichkeit als das
was auch immer schlecht hin dass ein
griechisches wort was ihr jetzt falsch
erkannt wurde wahrscheinlich ecstatic on
oder so das herausstellen zeitlichkeit
ist das ursprüngliche als ekstase hängt
damit auch zusammen das ursprüngliche
außer sich an und für sich selbst wir
nehmen daher die charakterisierten
phänomene zukunft gewesen haid gegen war
die ekstasen der zeitlichkeit sie ist
nicht vor dem 1 sein dass das erst aus
sich heraus tritt sollen ihr wesen ist
zeitung in der einheit der ekstasen das
charakteristische der den vulgären
zeitverständnis zugänglichen zeit
besteht unter anderem gerade darin das
sind ihr als einer puren anfangs und
endlosen jetzt folge der ekstatische
charakter der ursprünglichen
zeitlichkeit nivelliert ist diese
nivellierung selbst gründet aber in
ihren existenziellen sinnen nach einer
bestimmten möglichen zeitung gemäss der
die zeitlichkeit als eigentliche die
genannte zeit zeitigt wenn daher die der
verständlichkeit des daseins zu der zeit
als nicht ursprünglich und vielmehr
entspringt aus der eigentlichen
zeitlichkeit nachgewiesen wird dann
rechtfertigt sich gemäss dem zapatero
rief it.de nomination die benennung der
jetzt freigelegten zeitlichkeit als
ursprüngliche zeit
das ist jetzt wieder schwierig was wir
jetzt hier besonders beachten müssen ist
die ekstase also jetzt geht sie um die
präpositionen als zu und gewesen haid
gegenwart
die haben die präpositionen das aufsicht
zu und der orts richtung der vektoren
vielleicht können wir sagen die rektoren
auf sich zu zurück auf das die
vergangenheit ist das gewesene und das
begegnen lassen
als auf sich zu kann man natürlich auch
so sagen das dasein das macht hier ein
entwurf von sich selbst
das haben uns vielleicht ergänzt das
dasein das mit diesen gepunkteten raum
ist es da sein wie er sich selbst gerne
hätte ja das muss man die entwurf wenn
man entwirft sich wie man sich gerne
hätte als möglichkeit
deswegen das ist das auf sich zu also
man kommt man läuft auf sich zu als
jemand der man gerne wäre
so muss man das glaube ich noch mal ein
bisschen präzisieren ja wir haben ein
selbstbild ein wunsch von uns oder anti
ziel und wir setzen uns in die zukunft
wir planen uns und wir laufen in der
zukunft auf uns zu auf dieses modell was
wir da haben und dann kommen wir wieder
zurück ins sagen und dann wird
vielleicht könnte man dann sehen wir
auch dass wir gewissermaßen auch
beschränkt sind natürlich in der gewesen
halten das zurück auf wir müssen dann
den selbst entwurf mit unserer vor
fälligkeit die immer eine gewesen de ist
durch die vergangenheit bestimmte und
als solche fortdauernde existenz in eine
art von einklang bringen
wir müssen wieder realistisch werden und
wir müssen dann vor diesem extrem des
vergangenen und des zukünftigen
vielleicht auch so eine gesunde mitte
finden das könnte man auch sagen also
dass die gegenwart die synthese aus
zukünftigen und gewesen ist dass er eben
im lichte der unserer beiden extremen
möglichkeiten also dieses zukunft dieses
zukünftigen und es gewesen dass wir aus
diesen zwei extremen heraus eben auch
die gegenwart dann besonders reflektiert
betracht
also im sinne dieser synthese aus
möglichkeiten die uns vorgegeben sind
und beschränkungen die eben andauernd
durch unsere geworfen haid und durch
unsere vorbedingungen aus dieser diesen
beiden extrem müssen wir so eine art
mitte bilden und dann eben in der
gegenwart so handeln dass wir möglichst
viel von unserem ziel verwirklichen
können so kurz gesagt hatte man
vielleicht auch sagen
also es geht immer um richtungen um
bezüge auf sich zu zurück auf das was
man da war und das belegen lassen fonds
und das dass diese drei bezüge nennt
heiliger jeweils das außer sich dass
außer sich
hauser sich und
insofern als ich vom host es sich
handelt aus ich kann auch einfach nur
heißen wir stehen hier in relationen
hause sicher heißt wir nehmen bezüge auf
ein zukünftiges selbst von uns auf
unsere gewesen haid damit sehen wir uns
auf uns zurück wir gehen aber aus uns
heraus und kommt auf uns zurück und
dieses begegnen lassen ist auch auf
etwas anderes bezogen also wissen immer
in der relation zu etwas anderem auch zu
dem anderen unserer selbst und das etwas
außer sich ist das nennt er eben die
ekstase also ekstase heißt einfach nur
bis herausstehen daraus stehen also
immer dieses auf anderes bezogen das ist
letztendlich auch internationalität
bedeutet dieses gerichte zeit lassen und
sind ekstase der zukunft gewesen haid
und vergangenheit
ja
ja das ist noch ein wichtiger punkt
ekstase also gewesen haid gegenwart und
zukunft sind ekstasen der zeitlichkeit
und nicht derzeit ekstasen ekstasen
heißt es ist nicht einfach irgendwelche
teile der zeit oder subjektiven
erfahrungen der zeit oder irgendwelche
portionen auf einem zeitstrahl sonne
sind bezüge des da seid also
zeitlichkeit wird vom dasein her
verstanden und das dasein in der
zeitlichkeit an vor allem eben von der
zukunft von der zukünftig kite
ist heraus stehen also aus der
internationalität aus der bezogenheit es
da sind die zeitlichkeit die drei formen
der zeitlichkeit sind formen des zugs
des daseinsformen von relationen des
dasein bei der aufzeichnung der ekstasen
haben wir immer die zukunft an erster
stelle genannt das soll anzeigen dass
die zukunft in der ekstatischen einheit
der ursprünglichen und eigentliche zeit
nicht zeitlichkeit einen vorrang hat
wenngleich die zeitlichkeit nicht erst
durch eine anhäufung und absolute
ekstase nennt spitzeln je in der gleich
ursprünglichkeit derselben sich zeitig
aber innerhalb dieser sind die mode
derzeitigen verschieden und die
verschiedenheit liegt darin dass sich
die zeitung aus den verschiedenen
ekstasen primär bestimmen kann
die ursprünglich und eigentliche
zeitlichkeit zeitigt sich aus der
eigentlichen zukunft so zwar dass sie
zukünftig gewesen allererste gegenwart
weckt das primäre phänomen der
ursprüngliche und eigentlichen
zeitlichkeit ist die zukunft der vorrang
der zukunft wird sich entsprechend der
modifizierten zeitung der und
eigentlichen zeitlichkeit selbst
abwandeln aber auch noch in der ab fünf
tagen zeit zum vorschein kommen
interessant finde ich jetzt hier die
wendung eigentliche zukunft
die
allererste gegenwart weckt das ist
vielleicht auch ein schöner bezug nimmt
zukünftig gewesen
das interessante die zukunft ist
zukünftig gewesen also die zukunft das
ist das vor gelaufene und zurück
gelaufen also die gewesen haid entsteht
aus der rück bewegung von der zukunft
wieder zurück auf sich kommend sich
wieder vorfinden und seine gewesen hatte
erst als das ist das moment der zukunft
ist das vor laufen auf den entwurf und
das wolle man der gewesen hyde ist das
zurückkommen auf sich selbst in seiner
verbindlichkeit seiner beschränktheit
vielleicht und iris in diesem kreislauf
könnte man sagen kommt die gegenwart
eigentlich müsste ich die gegenwart hier
reinschauen gegenwart hier ist daraus
wird die gegenwart geweckt interessanten
also die gegenwart kommt an dritter und
letzter stelle also erst kommt die
zukunft es ist ja auch mal völlig also
wie würden wir den gemeinhin die die
reihenfolge der zeit bestimmt haben sie
eine idee was würden sie sagen kommt an
erster stelle gewöhnlich ja
ja ging war zukunft mehr so redet mit
dem vergangenheit gegenwart zukunft
oder man könnte auch sagen gut wir reden
von gegenwart vergangenheit suchen aber
normalerweise vergangenheit gegenwart
zukunft und hier er sagt zukunft
vergangenheit gegenwart denken sie wie
ein hebel zurück these antithese
synthese ganz ähnlich wie hier
wir haben die extreme these zukunft
antithese vergangenheit synthese
gegenwart also ein bisschen diesem
modell immer diese dreier struktur ja
die zeiten stehen nicht nebeneinander
sondern wir haben zukunft zukunft und
davon kommt dann letztendlich die
gewesen hyde
und dann erst kommt die gegenwart zu
hosen sich das vorstellen
und die zukunft ist das dasein ist
eigentlich hier drin das dasein ist
eigentlich den bezug zu allen das ist
das ist das modell also sie sehen er
bringt das ganze gefüge derzeit eine
neuordnung das ist dass das das bleiben
dabei heiliger die sorge ist sein zum
tode
die vorlaufenden entschlossenheit
bestimmen wir als das eigentliche sein
zu der charakterisierten möglichkeit der
schlecht wenigen unmöglichkeit dass das
in solchem seien zu seinem ende
existiert es da sind eigentlich ganz als
das sein dass es geworfen in den tod
sein kann es hat nicht ein ende an dem
es nur aufhört sondern existiert endlich
als auch schön beschrieben die
eigentliche zukunft die primär die
zeitlichkeit zeit liegt die den sinn der
vorlaufenden den entschlossenheit
ausmacht enthüllt sich damit selbst als
endlich allein geht trotz des nicht mehr
da seins meiner selbst die zeit nicht
weiter und kann nicht unbeschränkt will
es noch in der zukunft liegen und aus
ihr ankommen
also schön hat gut hat mir das gefallen
mit der zukunft
in solchen seien zu seinem ende das vor
laufen auf den tod existiert das dasein
eigentlich ganz als das sein dass es
geworfen in dem tod sein kann es hat
nicht ein ende an dem es nur aufhört
sondern existiert endlich alle das ende
ist nichts äußerliches so die grenze
sondern das ende ist ein modus der es
existieren
es ist nichts kaiserliches wo das dasein
aufhört sondern das ende ist immer schon
im dasein drin das dasein ist dynamische
beendigung könnte man sagen ja das
dasein ist existieren aufs ende hin vom
ende her
sozusagen das ende ist nicht der
endpunkt das ende ist ein modus der
existenz in dicken man kann aber sagen
dass da seien existierten ten dich oder
ist da sign and licht sicht sich schon
sowie heiligen dass endlich sich die
eigentliche zukunft die primär die
zeitlichkeit zeitig die dedizierten der
vorlauf dem entschlossen ausmacht
enthüllt sich damit selbst als endlich
genau also schauen wir ob ich hier noch
ein bisschen was habe ja das ist
vielleicht noch wichtig die versuchung
dazu die endlichkeit der ursprünglichen
und eigentlichen zukunft und damit der
zeitlichkeit zu übersehen bzw a priori
für unmöglich zu halten entspringt aus
dem ständigen vordringen des vulgäre
zeitverständnis wenn dieses mit recht
eine endlose zeit und nur diese kennt
dann ist damit noch nicht erwiesen dass
es diese zeit und ihre endlichkeit auch
schon verspielt
was besagt die zeit geht weiter und
vergeht weiter das bedeutet dass in der
zeit überhaupt und das in und aus der
zukunft insbesondere in welchem sinne
ist die zeit endlos dergleichen verlangt
aufklärung wenn die vulgären einwände
gegen die endlichkeit der ursprünglichen
zeit nicht bodenlos bleiben wollen
also hier ist noch wichtig dass er an
der vulgären zeit kritisiert dass es nur
eine endlose zeit kennen es ist die a3
und die beere diarra und die baureihe
ist unbegrenzt die denkt zeit nicht
einem ende vor dem hintergrund eines
endes sind sie läuft einfach weiter da
kommt auf und zwar etwas zu dann sterben
wir eben und dann läuft sie trotzdem
weiter und war ein weiteres mögliches
objekt läuft die zeit eben auch weiter
und er sagt jetzt das ist ein falsches
verständnis absolut gesehen schon aber
innerhalb der logik der ohne
eigentlichen zeit oder der des vulgären
zeitverständnis
wird zeit mit recht als endlos angesehen
also kurz gesagt die ekstatische zeit
die zeitlichkeit ist ein weiterer punkt
nicht nur dynamisch nicht räumlich und
modell anders geordnet sind sie ist auch
eine endliche zeit das ist ganz
entscheidend ist immer zeit von einem
ende her betrachtet immer eine zeit die
nur begrenzt ist also eine eine
limitierte zeit könnte man sagen ja eine
ähnliche zahl
das ist glaubt das entscheidende für die
existenzielle zeitlichkeit und der
heilige hier spricht
so dass noch zum schluss die bisherige
analyse der ursprünglichen zeitlichkeit
fassen wir in folgenden thesen zusammen
zeit ist ursprünglich als zeitung der
zeitlichkeit als welche sie die
konstitution der sorge struktur
ermöglicht die zeitlichkeit ist gewesen
hat ekstatisch zeitlichkeit zeitig sich
ursprünglich aus der zukunft die
ursprüngliche zeit ist endlich das ist
jeder mal so ein bisschen die
zusammenfassung aller sorge dieses
existenz faktizität und verfallen
das sind drei dimensionen sorge die
lassen sich zeitlich stehen und
zeitlichkeit ist immer bezug auf ein
anderes aus sich heraus und zeitlichkeit
ist darin immer endlich das ist auch
noch ein wichtiger punkt also immer nur
von grants an der grenze her gesehen
wird uns das ganze verständlich dann
sind wir jetzt hier am ende nicht nur
dieser sitzung sind auch am ende von
heiliger anbelangt vorerst mal
wir werden in der nächsten sitzung noch
mal ganz kurz darauf zurückkommen aber
ich glaube wir haben jetzt wird
ausführlich besprochen in zwei sitzungen
fast ich werde jetzt das sahen fassung
herumschicken und dann wollen wir in der
ich glaube haben wir noch eine sitzung
der letzte sind sie vor jetzt in der
letzten sitzung der nächsten woche
wollen wir uns mit mctaggart
auseinandersetzen der hat diesen begriff
der a3 und der c3 geprägt auch noch eine
wäre natürlich abc und dann wenn noch
ein bisschen zeit bleibt möchte ich mal
noch ein bisschen einen ausblick geben
also vielleicht eine halbe stunde
ich habe mir noch einiges physikalisches
zusammen gelesen hier also aus der
kosmologie da gibt es interessante
ergebnisse zum beispiel die these dass
die naturgesetze auch zeitig zu
verstehen sind das also naturgesetze
sich revolutionär dynamisch entwickelt
haben da werde ich ein bisschen was
vorstellen und vielleicht noch auf den
philosophen aus heidelberg namens
anderen friedrich koch eingehen der dazu
auch was
geschrieben hat ich biete außerdem noch
sprechstunden an und die schicke ich
ihnen auch in meinem nächsten rund herum
dann bis zur nächsten und letzten
sitzung